[music]
a volcano is one of the most unforgiving
Natural phenomena on Earth if you were
to fall into its magma fielded Center
your body would quickly bubble Up and
disappear without a trace so If they're
so good at getting rid of things has
Anyone tried it
before How would We transport all our
trash to
them and what dangers would be in
This is what if and here's what would
happen If WE dumped our trash into
volcan americans Alone generate about
254 million tons of trash per Year and
although dumping it  into volcanos might
sound like the perfect way to get rid of
it it wouldn't be that easy volcanes
might look like nature's garbage
incinerators but In reality they're much
more Dangerous and unstable not to
mention a lot Harder to get
to would overcome these  obstacles be
Worth It or would dumping our trash in
volcanos just cause even more Harm to
our
planet the first obstacle in our Quest
for volcanic garbage disposal would be
Finding an active volcano that can get
the job done There are only about 1500
potentially active volcanoes worldwide
and most of them aren't located anywhere
near humans for obvious reasons that
means getting all our trash an active
volcano could turn out to be Pretty
expensive and once We get there We might
Find out It's not even the right kind of
Active
volcano the kind  of volcano we'd be
looking for is called a Shield volcano A
slow erupting variety that contains the
iconic Lava lakes that gradually spew
out onto the earth unfortunately these
aren't very Common You're more likely to
come across their angry cousins ​​known as
str
volcanos str volcan are known for their
explosive eruptions caused by the
buildup of pressure from hot gas and
magma in other Words they're probably
not the safest location for the town
dump but Let's say We're Lucky Enough To
find ourselves a nice Active  Shield
volcano before We worry about the
logistics of getting our trash there if
you were one of the first waste
collectors hired to drive up to the vent
of a volcano you'd quickly start to
question your career
choices the vent of a volcano IS
treacherous environment  Full of
poisonous gases Lava splatter and
projectile Rocks and things only get
worse once you start throwing stuff
inside in 2002 a group of ethiopian
researchers threw a 30 kilogram bag of
trash into a volcano and the results
were
explosive Lava lakes are unstable so if
you pierce  their surfaces with something
cold like trash you'll Trigger a chain
reaction of explosions involving
pressurized and acidic steam So can you
Imagine How big these explosions would
be if you threw AN entire nation's trash
in there well to put it in perspective
rock Falls into Lava  lakes in Hawaii
have sent Lava 85 meters into the air so
itd probably look something like that
even If You Could safely get your trash
into the volcano you'd still have to
Worry About all the air pollution
created by burning our waste without
filters Plus not  all materials will
completely Break Down in Lava which
means that the polluting remnants could
erupt out and contaminate the
surrounding landscape not ideal if you
were hoping to burn nuclear waste for
example add these environmental impacts
On top of the fact that shipping all our
trash to these  volcanos would
significantly increase the carbon
footprint of the waste disposal and the
whole thing looks like a terrible
idea If We're going to burn our trash
Why not At least do it someplace where
we can use the heat released through
incineration to create new sources of
Energy or instead Maybe We could just
Shoot our garbage out into Space surely
there Can't Be any harmful effects there
right well That's a topic for another
What
if